yeah so if you want to play with me uh
feel free to send a challenge
but i said i was going to play the
sequence
see if i can find this name here we go
see queens
420. so earlier
this opponent
was asking me about stafford
how they always play
i think f3 and c3
and then i said challenge me
now here we are
uh let's play this move
i have to remember my staffer prep
d3 d3 is a good move
so white's playing like a very very
solid line
um i think my main idea is to go for f5
maybe get a pawn cube
f5 looks reasonable here
yeah there's some idea to play for
like white looks very very solid
which is probably just true but uh
there's still room to poken prod i know
this is rated too so
it's going to be a serious fight
casting is
interesting yeah i'll go for f4
f4 there's
i might be provoking this move which
i won't complain about
and it takes i take with night
enjoy the dark squares
oh i ordered a london fog
yeah
it's a steamed tea latte
earl grey tea
yeah the knights enjoying life
very tempted to play this move
which has a few purposes to it
a few other moves to consider
oh let's go for this
so one of the ideas is play queen a5
and just swing over and start attacking
on
the queen side
a lot of people are asking what i'm
gonna be for halloween
and to be honest
i'm gonna be traveling
so i don't think i'll be dressing up
at the airport
but maybe i'll bring my swan mask
masks are required at the airport so i'm
not sure if they'll allow that though
okay so yeah the reason why i played
queen g5 not only to prepare this
but also
there's a funny idea to take on e3
there's also like
let's start with
probably 92
but this looks more fun to take on e3
forcing this
and then play 92
what do we call this
this is like a
it's a discovered port eric how have you
been because it's a pin
a fork and a discovery
discovered pork
did i discover a new
tactic
i mean there's a the dork and the pork
but i don't know how to combine all of
them into
one word
okay
well this is pleasant
now i'm up a queen or a knight
why could i play king d2 but then i
would have eventually won the rook
up a dork
yeah i recently had a youtube video
called
something like a new chess tactic
and it came from a similar line in the
stafford
it was a dork
but this is an even newer chess tactic
um yeah let's go for the
queenside storm
not too afraid of white's discoveries
i am a little bit afraid of this knight
though
move back
so if a4 will play
b3 and if takes
take back with pawn use a file
looks like files are guaranteed to open
[Music]
yeah my opponent like was clearly
prepared in the opening though and white
was objectively better
this seems to be a storyline with
stafford is
you get us a bit worse position but it
still still offers a lot of practical
value
trickiness too
that opponent wants to double up
the knight does defend b2
so i need a few more things to help out
yeah the a pawn's enough
it's a pawn that breaks the camel's back
absolutely top tier tactic name oh thank
you
oh wait what a disco pork
oh a disco pork
like a discovered pork but disco is
short for discovery
oh that's a top tier name who came up
with that
who was the first person to say disco
pork
someone said discord
disco
oh a lot of people said disco pork
oh i wasn't looking at chat
that is a pretty amazing name though
a disco pork
oh now i wanna photoshop like a pig
in a party with a disco ball
uh oh i can queen
i could also pull the fabiano and make a
bishop
ah i have the hollow queen but it's
mates okay i'm happy thanks for the game
uh yeah that was pleasant
yeah so this queen g5 move kind of set
everything up
usually you don't want to align your
queen with opponent's bishop
but this was an exception because i've i
was setting up the disco pork
and white had to be really careful here
because if there's so many ways to go
wrong
if takes
i i don't get the pawn cube but i go for
the
dork this is
a double check dork discovered
fork um
[Music]
oh engine just says d4 and white's much
better
i guess if white
avoided
the tactical issues then the position
was still pretty good
i was also going to share because
before we played the game my opponent
had said in chat that they usually like
to play c3 or f3 and c3
which is good
against bishop to c5 c3 is a fine move i
believe
but
i was slightly hoping that after bishop
e6 my opponent would play c3
which is here at blunder because after
this this
this this this
we need to
i played bishop e6 to not be pinned and
now i can take the rook
um but my opponent didn't fall into that
anyway thanks for the game
equins 420.